[Aplausos]
bueno hoy quiero contarles dos historias
que significa muchísimo para mí la
primera es la historia de mi amiga fría
fillón nos conocimos en el año 2018 en
la isla griega de lesbos cuando llega la
traductora para médicos sin fronteras y
yo empezaba a coordinar el proyecto de
rowling tuve cuando nos conocimos fría
me contó que tenía 23 años que era
enfermera y que era organista me dijo
que una semana después me contó que era
refugiada
priva me dijo que también estaba casada
con un chico llamado a mí y que antes de
salir de kabul había estudiado medicina
pero no había podido terminar la carrera
priva constantemente me decía que estaba
muy feliz de poder ayudarnos en la
clínica
y que ahora que acnur le había dado un
espacio en una casa compartida con otras
familias refugiadas se sentía muchísimo
más segura de poder ayudar y es que en
moría cuando ellos recién llegaron les
robaron todo lo que tenía
vivir en el campo les daba muchísimo
miedo las mujeres
no pueden ir al baño en las noches por
miedo a ser atacadas o violadas
y el hacinamiento hace que los
conflictos interraciales y religiosos
que ya de por sí son muy graves se
vuelvan mucho peores
y es que en moría un campo construido
para 3.000 personas hoy viven más de 10
mil en karate efe un campo construido
para personas vulnerables muy cerca de
memoria hoy viven más de tres mil a
pesar de que está diseñado para 1000 y
una casa abandonada al lado de karate pe
viven todos los hombres solteros que
procesos tema humanitario no son
considerados como vulnerables
un día mientras tomábamos del té con
frío
amir y su familia me contaron que ellos
nunca quisieron salir de afganistán
pero que um
un día perdieron a su hijo y el padre de
mil en medio de un bombardeo
ese día cambió todo
decidieron buscar un traficante de
personas que les permitiera salir por la
ruta segura hoy lo llamado en la ruta
segura desde afganistán hacia europa
una vez tus cruces de lo que me cuentan
puede llegar a costar hasta tres mil
euros por persona
y está lleno de peligros
no solamente implica vivir a la
interperie por varias semanas esconderte
de la policía constantemente y
despojarse de todas y cada una de tus
pertenencias sino que también implica
exponerte o verte mucho más vulnerable a
sufrir violencia sexual
o trata de personas mediante tráfico
sexual
de hecho más de la mitad de las mujeres
que llegan al campo de moria hoy en día
han sufrido algún tipo de violencia
sexual o han sido víctimas de tráfico
estas mujeres dejan traumatizadas con
dolor y psicosomáticos
con que son producto del trauma no
tienen ganas de comer no tienen ganas de
vivir tienen una salud psicológica
mental y una salud física muy
deteriorada
estas mujeres se ven continuamente
forzadas a revivir su trauma todos los
días
esto generalmente pasa en turquía cuando
pasas del medio oriente por turquía
hacia europa
y las familias cuando ya logran pasar
todo el área de turquía que es muy
extensa
son embarcadas en un link que es
construido para 40 personas steding y
generalmente los traficantes meten 80
personas o más con chalecos salvavidas
que están hechos de espuma chalecos que
si es que te caes del agua te hundes en
lugar de mantenerse a flote
de hecho los niños con más suerte pueden
tener uno de esos chalecos que usamos
para las piscinas para nuestros sobrinos
o hijos y que están prohibidos para un
uso en más de diez metros de profundidad
no por nada le dicen al cruce en el
mediterráneo el cruce más peligroso
de hecho en el mediterráneo está
prohibido salvar vidas
las autoridades criminalista en la ayuda
humanitaria y puedes enfrentar cargos
como actor humanitario como yo
de tráfico de personas
lavado de dinero pertenecer a una
asociación criminal y espionaje contra
los gobiernos e incluso la semana pasada
que arreglé racquet enfrentó cargos por
desafiar a un barco de guerra
pero bueno
muchos de los que intentan llegar a
grecia lo logran pero muchos otros
no
el tram entre turquía y grecia es
simplemente de 8 km es un tramo que los
griegos hacen todos los días por una
suma de 18 euros y que lo hacen con
todas las comodidades
muchas de estas personas mueren en el
mar
de lo que va de 2010 y 9 519 personas
han muerto en el mar mediterráneo de
esta forma y solamente es de tres
semanas siete personas murieron en la
costa del scs
después de experimentar un viaje de esta
naturaleza priva decidió quedarse todos
los días en la clínica para ayudar a las
personas que han sufrido un viaje mucho
más grave que el que desea sufrir es la
nueva víctima de violencia sexual ella
no se sometió a tráfico ella en realidad
tuvo un viaje con suerte
pero entendía que estas mujeres que han
sido víctimas de este tipo de viajes
no solamente se someten al trauma al
dolor y a la desesperación de una
víctima de violencia sexual se somete
sino que también son víctimas de tener
este bagaje cultural super grande que no
les permite buscar ayuda externa
así que frío
siempre era nuestro vínculo humana no
era solamente nuestra traductora sino
también nuestra mediadora cultural con
estas personas de afganistán y de otros
lugares de medio oriente que hablaban
persa
frío les daba el calor humano que estas
personas necesitaban ella entendía que
tenía que hacer el vínculo humano entre
nosotras
y cada vez que yo necesitaba llenar
algún formulario de acnur para las
víctimas de violación habla seres
recientes priva era quien me ayudaba y
quien ayudaba estas personas quien se
quedaba con esas historias
y admira estuvieron varados de memoria
con un sello rojo que no les permitía
salir del scs por nueve meses después de
nueve meses obtuvieron este sello azul y
acá está en la pantalla un sello que
para todos los refugiados simboliza un
símbolo de esperanza o poder salir hacia
grecia atenas o cualquier lugar del
continente
y entonces priva y admiro al obtener
estos ellos decidieron quedarse vieron
la necesidad de todas las personas que
habían compartido su historia y se
quedaron listos
hoy free vaya me están esperando un
nuevo bebé
está traduciendo parado como bill y está
traduciendo para médicos sin fronteras
en lesbos conocí a cientos de personas
jóvenes como ellos cientos de personas
que me enseñaban
que creer en las personas es uno de los
regalos más grandes que la pena y la
caridad en realidad no mueven montañas
pero que creer en ellos y que darles el
espacio que necesitan mueve todos los
espacios que necesitan
en ecuador conocí a gente con estas
mismas características
dos de ellos son frank y dariana frank y
dariana de 22 y 20 años respectivamente
son dos de los más de 300.000 refugiados
que han venido de venezuela a ecuador
para buscar un lugar más seguro
dos de los más de 4.3 millones de
venezolanos que han tenido que salir de
sus hogares por la crisis humanitaria
y dariana me contaba en qué
esos vieron
el cambio en su en su ciudad el cambio
en mérida que ellos vieron cómo la
crisis económica hacía que sus personas
y las personas de la ciudad sufrieran
muchísimos cambios que los valores la
felicidad y la esperanza que se
respiraba en mérida antes ahora ya no
están presentes que ahora es la
corrupción y la violencia los el status
quo en la ciudad
y de hecho esa fue una de sus
principales razones para huir
tuvieron que abandonar sus estudios y
salir por la violencia que se respiraba
en mérida y para buscar no solamente un
futuro mejor para ellos sino también
para mantener a sus familias que se
quedaron con venezuela
el primero en salir fue frank llegó
hacia la frontera entre venezuela y
colombia acompañado de su madre y de
dariana
y justo antes de llegar al puente de la
policía venezolana lo paró le dijeron
que tenían que interrogarlo y que tenían
que revisar
después de horas de desaparecer la madre
de fran y daría han estado en
completamente desesperadas
así que frank apareció nuevamente y les
dijo que habían robado
le habían robado no solamente la mitad
de sus pertenencias sino todo el
efectivo que tenía para hacer el cruce y
le había robado a la policía venezolana
en medio de la desesperación porque si
un dinero no puedes cruzar decidieron
acudir a la comandancia de policía
esta comandancia de policía en la que
después de varias insistencias lograron
recuperar esos 40 dólares que le
permitirían llegar desde venezuela hasta
ecuador
frank una vez que recupere este dinero
emprendió su viaje y la madre de frank y
dariana se quedaron esta noche en la
ciudad hicieron un búnker en su
habitación porque tenían miedo de que la
policía pudiera tomar represalias
mariana no se demoró mucho en salir
un día fue atacada con armas cuando
estaba caminando hacia la universidad
con su hermana pequeña y con su familia
y ese día decidió que ya no podía
quedarse
al igual que las historias que escuchaba
en grecia
las historias de los venezolanos que
vienen a su ecuador o hacia otro lugar
de latinoamérica son llenas de
experiencias traumatizantes y están muy
fuertes son viajes que nadie emprender y
así de lo que tiene que huir no es peor
frank me contaba que los dos cruces que
hizo desde venezuela hasta ecuador el
status quo era una inseguridad que él
nunca había experimentado
que tenía que pagarle a malandros con
armas semiautomáticas para que le
dejaran pasar y que las personas que no
contaban con el dinero y no encontraron
una persona que como frank ayudar a
otras para poder pasar con dinero
terminaban muriendo
cuando llegar a un ecuador frank y
dariana enfrentaron una situación
bastante difícil
y es que no solamente fueron víctimas de
excitación es completamente inhumanas
cuando estuvieron en el cruce sino que
cuando llegaron acá fueron víctimas de
ataques de xenofobia
y en cuando contrataron encontrar
trabajo y con trataron de encontrar un
lugar en donde vivir fue sumamente
difícil darían encontró trabajo con un
inmigrante
entendía su situación y que le ayudó a
encontrar un trabajo y frank que trabaja
en sistemas encontró un trabajo
que no gana mucho pero que permite que
él viva aquí y que también ayuda a su
familia en venezuela
frank y dariana que nos están
acompañando en la audiencia
hacen encontrar una sociedad en quito
encontraron un grupo
y encontraron un lugar en donde
pertenece
ellos ahora son parte de una comunidad y
todos los días van a clases de francés
en las mañanas para poder cumplir su
sueño de ir a estudiar en europa
en junio de 2019 acnur reveló que a
nivel mundial rompimos un récord que
nunca nos propusimos romper
hoy más de 70.8 millones de personas
están desplazadas a nivel mundial
estas personas
han llegado a un récord incluso más
grande que el que llevó a la creación de
acnur hace 60 años
es un número que sigue creciendo
exponencialmente y que se prevé que siga
creciendo
se estima que cada hora 25 personas como
frank mariana y free ba tienen que salir
de sus hogares
y que cada día treinta y siete mil
personas son desplazadas de sus hogares
por situaciones que perturban el orden
de sus países
hoy más 70.8 millones de personas en
todo el mundo se han visto obligadas a
huir de su hogar hoy después de todas
las reacciones que supuestamente nos
dejó el pasado
seguimos expresando si seguimos
expresando xenofobia seguimos expresando
nos como si lo único que tuviéramos que
sentir por un refugiado español
seguimos despojándolos de su humanidad
como si su estatus migratorio
significará que ellos son menos humanos
aunque si estas personas
por debido a su historia ya no pueden
tener un buen futuro
seguimos pensando que estas personas que
lo han perdido todos no nos pueden
enseñar más de fortaleza de resiliencia
o de amor de lo que nosotros nos damos
crédito y seguimos enfocándonos en las
cifras como si éstas fueran las únicas
cosas que importan como en lugar de
darnos cuenta de que estás
de que estas son las historias que
merecen ser contadas
historias que te enseñan a creer en la
bondad en la resiliencia
en el poder de estas personas que te
enseñen que darles un espacio para poder
empoderarse
y poder seguir adelante es sumamente
importante no solamente para ellos sino
para nosotros como sociedad
historias que te enseñan que la caridad
sin esperanza es completamente
incompatible con la humanidad que
intentamos procesar
así que qué podemos hacer desde nuestro
lugar para cambiar esto
podemos escuchar sus historias darnos
del trabajo de conocerlos como personas
saber de dónde vienen saber quiénes son
saber a qué se enfrentan podemos como yo
compartir historias en redes de todo lo
que sepamos compartir todo lo que
entendamos de la crisis de refugiados
para que otras personas puedan hacer de
ésta su causa
podemos tratar de amplificar las voces
de estas personas que no tienen un lugar
en donde amplificar la
podemos mantenernos informados de la
situación en sus países de origen
incluso cuando los medios ya no están
reportando sobre eso porque los medios
no dejan de reportar porque ya no pasa
los medios dejan de reportar porque ya
no es de un interés común
podemos consumir los productos de estas
personas y comprar en sus negocios o en
los negocios los contraten podemos donar
a organizaciones de la población civil
no solamente donar dinero sino también
donar nuestro tiempo y nuestras voces
podemos instar a las autoridades de
incluso desde aquí especialmente a las
autoridades europeas a dejar de
criminalizar la ayuda humanitaria porque
salvar vidas no es un crimen salvar
vidas es un deber
así que si hacemos todo esto juntos
vamos a poder mostrar el lado humano de
esta crisis y mostrando el lado humano
espero que podamos poner nuestro granito
de arena
para mostrar lo que se necesita y para
poder cambiar esta realidad gracias